WITH RODRIGUES AND GUENTZEL ANDT
A BIT OF
FOR AN ODD-MAN RUSH AND THE
THREE-ON-ONE AND TKACHUK, TO
FOR HIM HERE TONIGHT.
TKACHUK, INTO THE ZONE.
KNOCKEDOH, BOY, THE FLAMES HAVED
SOME CHANCES AND JARRY HAS BEEN
GOOD WITH COULD
NOT TAKE THAT PASS.ICKED OFF BY
LETANG, PRESSUERE, WITH CONTROLD
THIS IS LINDHOLM THIS TIME
THROUGH
>> Rick: THE STICK, LOST THERE,
AND NOW SCORES!
[ PAST
THE DEFENSEMAN AND THEN WHERE
DOES HE HERE, PLAYED
INTO THE CORNER, NOT TAKE IT ANW
LAFFERTY.
AND IT IS KNOCKED FREE.
HOW IT E
RIGHT THERE, LITERALLY RIGHT
THROUGH HIS FEET T T SECRETS. TY
GROUP, OWNER OF THE RED SOX AND
THE
POST.
>> Rick: AND I LIKE THAT YOU
CALLED IT ROUTINE AND
HE WILL FIRE IT AROUND AND HE
KNOWS THAT LINDHOLM IS RIGHT FRY
SCORE!
OFF OF A STICK.
IN THE SLOT.
JUST A
TERRIFIC PASS AND THEN A BETTER.
COLEMAN WITH HIM NOW. WITH TANEH
GAUDREAU,,H!
AND NOW THE TWO-ON-ONE THE OTHE,
LEADING TO A
GETS A SHOT
MONTREAL CANADIENS.TOWARDS
>> Rick: AND SEAN MONAHAN NOW,
THE FIRST SHOOTER, MONAHAN HERE
OF THAT JARRY MAGIC RUBBED
OFF ON THE GOAL OF MARKSTROM.
>> Rick: SIDNEY CROSBY ON
MARKSTROM.
HE WILL SWING OUT TOLETANG HAS O
SCORE, AND A MARKSTROM SAVE WILL
WIN IT, LETANG, HE ON TO
ROUND FOUR.
>> Kelly: : GIAPANE UP
NEXT.
MANGIAPANE
SHOOTER MANGIAPANE AND TAKING
AWAY THAT ANG
>> Rick: LINDHOLM NEXT FOR
CALGARY, ROUND FIVE, LINDHOLM ON
HAT PUCK UP.
WORKING IN NOW ON IT.
ON NOW TO ROUND SIX.
>> Kelly: I THINK THAT HE DID,
RIRI
PIECE OF IT.
>> Rick: DARRYL SUTTER
ONE, A FAIRLY SIMPLE SAVE
>> Rick: THE SEVENTH ROUND,
MIKAEL BACKLUND, UP NEXT. FLAMEY
[ Applause ]O MOVE, HE
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Rick: THE FLAMES, THIS HE WIN
IT, 2-1 - -